♪ ♪
>> Martha: WELCOME BACK,
EVERYBODY.
WE ARE HERE TO TELL YOU THAT THE
WAR ON POLICE IS ABSOLUTELY
RAGING.
IN THE PAST WEEK ALONE, 14
OFFICERS HAVE BEEN SHOT.
TWO CONNECTICUT POLICE OFFICERS
GUNNED DOWN IN THE LINE OF DUTY
THIS WEEK, AND THEY WERE
POSSIBLY AMBUSHED, LED TO THE
SCENE BY A FALSE CALL FOR HELP.
OFFICER ALEX DIED AT THE SCENE.
HE HAD JUST CELEBRATED HIS FIRST
WEDDING ANNIVERSARY THIS SUMMER
IN JUNE, AND POLICE OFFICER
DUSTIN DIED AT THE HOSPITAL.
HE WAS UNMARRIED DAD OF TWO, AND
HIS WIFE IS EXPECTING THEIR
THIRD CHILD OF YOUR JOINING US
NOW IS FRANK, FOUNDER OF THE
TUNNELS TO TOWER FOUNDATION, AND
HE IS READY TO HELP OUT IN A BIG
WAY.
ALWAYS GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH US,
BUT SAD TO HAVE YOU WITH US,
BECAUSE I MEAN THE ARTS HAVING
TO KEEP DOING THIS JOB OF
REACHING OUT AND HELPING THESE
FAMILIES, MAKING THAT PHONE CALL
TO THEM AND SAYING I KNOW YOU
ARE IN THE DARKEST MOMENT OF
YOUR LIFE, BUT WE ARE GOING TO
BE THERE FOR YOU.
>> IT SAD, AND IT'S DISGUSTING,
WHAT'S GOING ON IN AMERICA.
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
HAPPENING ALL OVER THE COUNTRY,
BUT OUR FOUNDATION, WE MADE A
PROMISE TO OUR FIRST RESPONDERS.
CERTAINLY OUR POLICE OFFICERS,
THAT YOU LEAVE, GIVE THE KIDS A
KISS GOODBYE, YOU DO NOT COME
HOME, WE ARE GOING TO MAKE SURE
YOUR FAMILIES ARE NOT LEFT
BEHIND.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT WE ARE
GOING TO DO FOR THEM, HIS
BEAUTIFUL WIFE, LAURA.
SPOKE TO HIS MOTHER EARLIER
TODAY.
SHE SAID THAT THIS IS A
NIGHTMARE, WHAT THEY ARE GOING
THROUGH.
SHE COULD NOT SPEAK, SHE WAS
CRYING SO MUCH ON THE PHONE.
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER.
WE HAVE TO SAY THEIR NAMES
BECAUSE WE CANNOT FORGET THE
SACRIFICES THAT THEY MAKE EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
WE HAVE MADE A PROMISE TO TAKE
CARE OF THE FAMILY.
>> Martha: YOU KNOW, THERE HAS
BEEN SO MUCH BACKLASH IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS AGAINST
POLICE.
YOU LOOK AT THESE FOLKS, GREG,
THAT COME OUT TO DO THE JOB.
IT IS INTERESTING THAT YOU SAY
"SAY THEIR NAMES."
YOU NEED TO SAY ALL OF THE
NAMES.
PEOPLE WHO ARE DYING AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT, ALL DIFFERENT
SITUATIONS.
>> Greg: I DO NOT MEAN TO
SOUND CALLOUS, BUT I CANNOT KEEP
UP WITH THE VIOLENCE.
IT AMAZES ME THAT THERE ARE SOME
NETWORKS HE WOULD PLAY PART OF A
VIDEO, POLICE MALFEASANCE,
PERCEIVED MALFEASANCE OVER AND
OVER AGAIN FOR WEEKS, BUT NO --
MAYBE THEY WILL TALK ABOUT THIS
ONCE.
MAYBE THEY WILL NOT EVEN MENTION
IT BECAUSE THERE IS NO RACIAL
ELEMENT TO MOST OF THE STUFF FOR
ANY ELEMENT OF THE STUFF, SO YOU
DO NOT HEAR ABOUT IT.
YOU SAID SOMETHING DURING THE
BREAK, THE MOST RECENT HORRIBLE
ACTS OF CRIMINALITY, AND YOU
JUST KIND OF SAID THERE IS A
SICKNESS OUT THERE.
AND I THINK WE ALL KIND OF FEEL
LIKE THERE'S A SICKNESS OUT
THERE.
WHAT IS THAT SICKNESS?
>> IT STARTS IN THE HOME.
MY PARENTS SAID RESPECT YOUR
ELDERS.
RESPECT LAW ENFORCEMENT.
YOU DID.
LITTLE THINGS LIKE THAT IN
SCHOOL.
YOU GET TAUGHT THAT WHEN YOU SEE
A POLICE OFFICER, YOU SAY
THANK YOU FOR PROTECTING US.
THOSE LITTLE THINGS THAT MAKE A
BIG DIFFERENCE.
A LOT OF MEDIA AND OTHER PEOPLE
I THINK COPS ARE BAD.
THERE IS A FALSE NARRATIVE OUT
THERE, AND WHEN ONE CUP DOES
SOMETHING BAD, THEY BLAME EVERY
COP.
YOU CANNOT DO THAT.
THEY GIVE US THE SOCIETY THAT WE
HAVE.
WITHOUT THEM, WE HAVE NOW
AMERICA.
SAD TO SAY THAT WE ARE RIGHT ON
THE CUSP OF SOMETHING BAD
HAPPENING IN AMERICA.
WE BETTER TAKE CARE OF IT.
IT STARTS OUT THE LOWEST LEVEL,
MEANING AT THE HOME.
THE PARENTS HAVE TO SAY THAT
POLICE OFFICERS ARE GOOD.
>> Martha: COPS ARE TIRING
LEFT AND RIGHT.
THEY ARE BRAVE TO SAY I WANT TO
BE A POLICE OFFICER BECAUSE IT
IS NOT WHAT IT WAS.
>> ALSO VERY BRAVE AND HEROIC
FOR PEOPLE TO STAND UP AND SAY I
AM GOING TO DONATE A LOT OF
MONEY.
SUCH A WEALTHY COUNTRY, VERY
GENEROUS COUNTRY, BUT YOU HAVE A
LOT OF THESE FUND-RAISERS WHERE
THEY ARE DONATING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO SAVE -- I DON'T KNOW,
A SEAL, SPOTTED OWLS.
NOT TO SAY THAT THAT IS NOT
IMPORTANT, BUT WHAT YOU GUYS ARE
DOING IS SO REAL, WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT THE IMPACT IT HAS.
THE REAL WORLD IMPACT IT HAS.
TALK ABOUT THE GENEROSITY OF THE
PEOPLE THAT YOUR ORGANIZATION
HAS WORKED WITH.
>> WE ASK FOR $11 A MONTH, AND
THAT MAKES A BIG DIFFERENCE IN
HIS FAMILY'S LIVES.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO HELP OVER 50
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT, DIED IN THE
LINE OF DUTY PROTECTING US.
137 HAVE GIVEN THEIR LIVES THIS
YEAR.
IT'S INCREDIBLE.
WE CANNOT DO IT WITHOUT THE
GENEROSITY OF OUR VIEWERS.
PEOPLE SHOULD KNOW THAT 95% OF
EVERY DOLLAR IS DONATED.
IT IS GOING TO THESE FAMILIES.
YOU SEE WHERE YOUR MONEY GOES.
THEIR MORTGAGES GOING TO GET
PAID OFF 100% WHEN YOU DONATE.
AT SOME IMPORTANT THAT PEOPLE
SEE WHERE THEIR MONEY IS GONE,
AND WHAT BETTER WAY TO TAKE CARE
OF THESE FAMILIES THAT JUST LOST
THEIR LOVED ONES?
>> Harold: IN THE GREEN ROOM,
1,000 EVENTS THAT
TUNNELS TO TOWER DID ACROSS THE
NATION.
GIVE US A LITTLE COLOR, TELL
VIEWERS HOW THEY CAN BE A PART
OF THIS AND HEALTH GOING
FORWARD.
>> WE ARE PROUD THAT WE HAVE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF VOLUNTEERS
ACROSS AMERICA THAT HAVE JOINED
US ON A MISSION.
THE MISSION IS SIMPLE.
LET US DO GOOD.
TAKE CARE OF THESE MEN AND WOMEN
WHO GO OUT EVERY SINGLE DAY TO
PROTECT US.
SO MANY PEOPLE HAVE JOINED US.
3,000 DIFFERENT EVENTS PUT ON
FOR US.
WE ARE NOT PUTTING THEM ON.
BECAUSE OF THAT, WE ARE ABLE TO
RAISE THAT KIND OF MONEY.
YOU CAN DO THE MATH.
MORTGAGE FREE HOMES FOR THE
SERVICE MEMBERS.
DO THE MATH.
YOUR MORTGAGE TIMES 200.
WE CAN ONLY DO IT BECAUSE OF THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE JOINED US IN
THIS GREAT NATION.
>> Dagen: I HAVE PHOTOS FROM
JASON RIVERA'S FUNERAL WHO DIED
IN THE NYPD.
HOW MUCH MONEY DO YOU NEED TO
RAISE?
>> IT AVERAGES OUT NEARLY
$330,000.
SOME MORE, SOME LESS.
BUT BELIEVE IT OR NOT, YOU BRING
PEOPLE TOGETHER.
IT GETS DONE.
THAT IS WHAT WE LEFT.
A BLUE-COLLAR FOUNDATION
BRINGING MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
TOGETHER, NOT JUST A FEW PEOPLE.
DON'T GET ME WRONG.
>> Martha: WE WILL TAKE THAT
TOO.
>> Dagen: WRITE YOU A CHECK
FOR $350,000 RIGHT NOW.
>> I HAVE NO DOUBT THAT YOUR
VIEWERS ARE GOING TO RESPOND TO
THIS.
$11 A MONTH.
YOU CAN HELP SOMEBODY.
THE DETECTIVES ASSASSINATED IN
NEW YORK, THE OFFICER WAS
ASSASSINATED.
NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
THEY WERE ASSASSINATED.
WE BETTER BE THERE TO TAKE CARE
OF THE FAMILIES.
THAT IS WHAT WE ARE HERE DOING
TODAY.
>> Martha: THANK YOU FOR
EV